i purposely obviously don't look up
stuff on the internet it's i think it's
poison for the most part
i am captain
[Music]
america oh god
well
i know
so you're gonna have to forgive me
because i don't know a ton about marvel
cinematic universe history i know that
hydro is like a hydra's bath
so i think his it would be
he'd be looking for the first person to
i guess take down if if someone if he
heard hill hydra i think he'd be he'd be
on his feet trying to take somebody down
i i
was nervous that i
they got the wrong person uh because i
didn't know what i who they
wanted me to be and then they
they said oh no it's this guy and this
is sort of his story arc and
and uh
they
they thought that i was you know right
for the role and then i could do a good
job and then i thought about it for a
little bit and when i first turned it
was like oh
i got it
oh no here's the thing uh i'm i'm not
tony stark i'm not dr banner okay i
don't have i don't have the flashiest
gadgets i don't have super strength it's
very physical it uh requires you know
you're there for 12 10 10 hours a day
trying to
a lot of physicality
so that they're you know you're tired
and you're sore and you're trying um
well
not 25 anymore it takes a little bit
longer to recover and you know you got
to be in a little bit better shape i i
think than i thought originally to
sustain and then mentally it's like yeah
you kind of got to get over the fact
that like you're wearing this helmet
that you can't you it's like how do i
act on the stupid thing you know like
how do i act in the suit it's
it's a totally
crazy thing to wear when you're wearing
it looks kind of when you're when when
you're doing it you're like does this
look totally stupid or is it cool i
can't tell because
you're just you know you're you know
you're acting you're acting in a with a
big screen behind you have no idea
what's there but so you kind of have to
remind yourself like okay i'm not forget
about the suit you know just forget
about it that was probably you know
mentally you just have to forget about
what you're wearing i'm i'm i i stay in
my house a lot i'm not i don't i don't
know no one no one recognized no one's
recognized never recognizes me because i
probably have this huge beard known and
a mask on half the time
so i don't know it feels fine i
purposely obviously don't look up stuff
on the internet so i think it's poison
for the most part
and
it doesn't help me like be better at my
job or feel better certainly doesn't
help anybody feel better about
themselves so i don't i don't read
anything i don't look up anything i just
live my life and so
someone else said something but no one's
i don't know i guess no one no one
recognized me it's great i like to keep
it that way i feel like since i saw this
one i don't need to see any more because
this one is definitely the winner
with the up guy
like the old man from up in the
that's the best one
that that to me is like
whoever did that i wish that they would
like come how i don't know how you can
find who like the first person who did
it was but they should be given an award
by the internet i don't think i was ever
in disbelief i don't know if i'm the guy
that you really want because i'm i'm not
i've been i haven't done a lot of mcu
type stuff it wasn't what i did but they
they liked that about what it was so it
wasn't disbelief it was sort of just not
knowing if i could do it myself
but now i'm i'm happy with what it was
if you don't think that you can be good
in the role and you don't
or you don't like it then just don't do
it you know it doesn't matter how big or
small the role is you just do things
that you think you can be good at
i know all you have to do
a word of advice then stay the hell out
of my way
you